today's legend is none other than
27-year world champion manuel astra
which i verified nobody was lecturing
before me on at all so of course you can
spend days talking about such a world
champion who was really one of the when
you see top 10 lists of what the best
world champions are many times his name
sneaks in even though there are not just
world champion best players ever and for
a reason now we will see him at actually
different in different roles and also of
course you'll notice by the dates that
the ages are also he's I'm sure he games
different stages of his life like you
see the comment here does actually I
left it which is very worthwhile to read
it says that no story about Velazquez
chess career is complete without the
following famous game this was written
by Garry Kasparov whose annotated the
game to chess base and maybe the game
was not perfect and the computers
nowadays will find some flaws in it and
you have to really analyze it very
carefully the point is not just to
concentrate on the game but as just to
see it as kind of a symphony just enjoy
the game as itself without we can go
over some variations but we don't need
to go over a great detail that's not the
point if you want to analyze this game
carefully you can pick it up I mean this
was played in st. Petersburg 1914 every
database has it even online if you just
put the names in the year you will
immediately get the game analyzed by the
best players so the point is to just see
a strategical masterpiece lets me forget
the player with the black pieces is for
cyril Capablanca an ex-world champion as
well who is famous for his amazing end
gameplay and here he gets played out
played in a middle game towards the end
game so it'll be I'll show you three
games that would just does the first one
so without further ado we are going into
a Royal Lopez a 6k takes and Kasparov
gives an exclamation mark in parentheses
to this map not because movies this move
is objectively stronger than let's say
Bishop a4
because against someone like kappa
blanka it was a pedagogic li correct
decision to go into a slightly inferior
endings that is gonna make him suffer
and feel a little uncomfortable because
basically he is reversing the roles he
is playing that the kind of game that he
that his opponent wishes that he could
have had white him and we will see this
also in the second game but with a
different characteristic so pawn takes
again those of you are not very familiar
with the opening and wondering why black
is taking away from the center well the
point is that developing the Queen in
developing the bishop outweighs the pawn
structure in this position so d4 Lasker
specialty after of course later on in
modern times we know that castles is
probably the most flexible move another
move to play is Knight c3 but he
believed in the quick trading of the
Queens and trying to prove that the four
pawns on the King side Center against
the black three are it's almost like
being an extra pawn up let me show you
what I mean after takes takes takes
takes you can see that white has HGF and
an e pawn black only has the three pawns
and while black has four pawns here it's
almost like three and a half two White's
three so it's in a sense if I took one
of the C pawns of the board just for a
second let's say do something like this
you will say okay white is winning
here's an extra pawn right and it's not
entirely true you see that black has two
bishops and yet as many tactical means
two in which to compensate for the pawn
majority this game was not a classical
example of how to do it right so Bishop
d6 okay again I think that most common
today is Bishop d7 followed by quick
casting long and black is supposed to be
pretty okay but that isn't it is not a
mistake or anything Knight c3 normal 97
castles castles so far everything is
going normal f4 okay step number one in
the the plan white wants to show that he
has an extra pawn in the center he wants
to utilize it now black has to be
objective about how to treat it in the
game he goes Ruki eight funny enough the
computer stockfish six says that this is
a perfectly fine move but Kasparov says
quotes and agrees with
dr. Tara she said f5 immediately trying
to undermine the situation after pawn
takes knight takes black gets great
activity with his bishops for example if
the bishop somehow gets here after the
trade of pieces then this pawn c2 is
gonna be tickled forever so that's gonna
be somewhat of a discomfort so white
plays a 5 again the most natural Bishop
c5 pinning tonight Bishop e3 I'm
guessing the capablanca already in this
position felt that this is auspicious
the pawn on e5 looks very strong but now
the counterintuitive continuation of
taking taking with the idea Bishop c5 b6
stopping it and now all of a sudden
black is very much in the game each side
has a bishop de Visser Chavez opposite
color and black is gonna play something
like c5 Bishop b7 okay and again you put
it in the computer the computer is is
quite convinced that black is doing okay
so going back after this he played rook
e8 again in itself not a blunder Knight
to b3 again in anticipation that if you
played something like let's say e 5
Bishop c5 just pins the night so he
moves it out of the way again the knight
is more flexible this way and he played
f6 to stop a5 now I played a very very
good move again I don't think it
necessarily gives him a huge advantage
but I think that it's fundamentally a
hard move to make I have to tell you the
first time I saw this game when I stood
the move I thought I'm gonna quit just
because when you see this move you think
yourself everything ever learned about
just about the the traditional way of
how to play chess for squares all of a
sudden it's gone so watch f5 and every
book every commentator gives it an
exclamation mark
well again justifiably because you
cannot push if I forget about that dream
therefore you have to work around it and
at first you say wait a minute what am I
missing here this e 5 square is in this
mind forever
no the answer is no it's not so easy to
to do it if there was let's say a black
knight on c6 right now different
ballgame but the way it is right now as
it is it's different so now in this
position b6 was played again a comment
was made about black
very understandably wanting to put the
bishop on the long diagonal very very
logical the alternative would have been
to play Bishop d7 and after this to play
here
and the bishop might end up being even
on c8 and I know it's not the most
natural on patient but it's a very
patient way to play that's the kind of
thing that kappa blanka cannot do i mean
it's very hard to play money is an
active activity seeker so what is the
difference I will explain after Bishop
up to b6 Bishop f4 again a very very
good move immediately putting the
challenge to the bishop and now
capablanca who probably for sorted after
f5 Bishop f4 would be the natural
continuation continues with this plan he
plays Bishop e7 probably not a good man
again it looks very natural to allow the
under bling of the pawns but like I tell
in many of my lectures and many examples
that I have in my in my work material
it's like trading one advantage for
another here you you just you undable to
pawns this is of course good for the
defensive player however the pawn
structure in tighten its entirety a 6b
6d 6d 6 becomes very vulnerable and also
the squirrels around it become weak it's
still not fatal but it becomes more
difficult to play so Bishop d7 of course
just to mention the right continuation
just for the sake of historical furnace
taking taking here here here very very
good that's very very good look after
you the computer said something like
rook d7 rook c8 and again it looks it's
illusionary the rook will have to leave
very very quickly after the bishop comes
to from b7 to c6 all I have to do is
just defend upon for a second so this
position is solid for black however you
played here Bishop takes d6 very strong
pawn takes Knight d4 already the knight
is becoming a bit mischievous wanting to
come to e6 and probably in kappa blanka
thought i don't know what he really
thought it's really tough to say
Kasparov seems to think as far as seem
to think that the best would have been
Bishop c8 and he claims that Capablanca
was too proud to retreat to the bishop
to admit that he that the plan of Bishop
to
six and Bishop d7 was wrong and he has
to go back psychologically was a bit
hard to do kind of a moral victory for
the opponent but sometimes you have to
be practical probably stopping ninety
six in this position would have been the
right choice instead he just makes the
hole deeper he plays here to activate
the rookie monster van rook defending
the D pawn and after this rook t7 that
was his idea
so already we understand that Lasker has
has a very serious positional victory a
knight on c6 is a real pain a real thorn
in the side very hard piece to deal with
but how to continue watch what he does
not take I want you to take like a
mental imprint of this position in your
head because that's what the real game
begins until now it was a build-up now
the action begins take a mental picture
of it and see what happened in the final
position it's almost like only white
moved you think yourself wait a minute
blacks position looks kind of similar
but the white position just like a
hurricane move the pieces watch what
happened
okay ruk ad one doesn't need much
explaining Knight to c8 trying to
maneuver the pieces rook F to b5 okay
hard to argue black is doing everything
normal here rookie seven before I should
make a note that maybe in this position
before would have been an interesting
move to play but I can totally
understand his reluctance to change the
structure because when you play
something like b4 then c4 becomes very
weak a4 becomes very weak and your
pieces become a bit passive it's kind of
a very committal move to make but
allowing y to play b4 and fixing the
pawns is no picnic either
so watch Ruki seven here king f7 a3
again very quiet he doesn't really need
to do that he can play king after
immediately for example now in my
opinion and I even asked one of the
Oracles which is the engines he thinks
that it's time for block to make an
investment he needs to take on e6 yes
the rook is worth five yes a knight and
upon our word for but the position is so
closed that it's going to be again the
enough proof is going to shift to whites
he's gonna have to prove that his extra
look for a night extra exchange is going
to win the game playing passively well
the result was never in doubt he needs
to sacrifice right now but again very
hard lived hard to blink Capablanca for
not doing it of course he saw it both
sides saw it velasca allowed it in kappa
blanka could have done it it's a very
practical decision for a computer cold
blooded computer with no emotions it's
not a big deal it's just gonna suck the
exchange and play the best moves for a
human it's much different so he played
quietly with Bishop a a mistake for sure
definitely a wrong plan so King F to Roo
k7 the idea clearing the seventh rank
maybe he can play a five it's a moment
but again he has to be very accurate
because remember when you open up the
position for someone who's better
developed you're asking for it so g4
already the idea is to push the pawn to
g5 eight six white could have played
aged for now but again is in no rush
Oscar is playing lots of prophylactic
move lots of preparation route d3 again
preparing the roof to go on the
third-ranked a5 finally h4 takes takes
rookie seven again as far I've said a
said retreat understand the ball again
what what to do it's very very hard to
suggest a good move I mean the rook but
alone on the a file the a file is kind
of a dead end
white is about to go g5 and the position
is about to burst all the black pieces
are so passive watch rook e8 night c8
Bishop a8 you cannot get a good game
with just one active piece so rookie
seven King f3 again no rush the pond is
going to go to g5 at leisure rook to g8
King at four g6 okay dying for some
activity
now of course white was just about to go
g5 with a huge advantage every white
piece is better than the black pieces
just a masterpiece so here and here the
computer says the g5 would have been
used for
white it's understandable because he's
really ready for it
but Oscar again in no rush and he plays
this any allows g5 check I'll turn ative
Lee sorry if takes takes ready to play
94 so here g5 just looks really gluey
from blacks point of view look at the
two minor pieces on the left side of the
board they tell the story it's not
everyday you see someone at the car
level of josé raúl capablanca with
though these two pieces like that
usually is on the winning side of such
examples so we played g5 king of three
and now he made maybe the last mistake
96 after that black is just completely
lost it's understandable that the six
activity but I think that the best move
would have been to take on h4 again very
very hard move to play I Spencer
specially since the pawn is going to
come back but that's the best
recommendation so 96 takes takes rook h3
no way he's gonna take the pawn on d6 as
you can see in this position after rook
d6 94 route goes back route h8 activity
all of a sudden the knight is good and
then I can come to e5 sometimes and the
rook is coming no need never allow can't
apply if you don't have to the point is
not worth it so rook h3 controlling the
file so after 94 rook a 1 there's going
to be 2 files to control and black is
just running out of ideas so he tries to
play here protecting his pawn this way
King g3 kingi 8 ruk h1 now route k h8 is
coming Bishop e7 and now the brilliancy
I should have actually paused for a
second but this is probably one of the
most famous moves on the chess position
the black pieces are so passive of
course rook h8 can win precisely if you
play rook h8 rook to the 2 here it's
winning for sure white is just didn't
spoil anything but Lasker just clear and
sacrifice the ideas to vacate the e4
square for his Knight
well I'm about to take on f6 and just
have an extra two pawns I mean extra
pawn to F ones that are past so he took
it 90 for threatening a family fork on
f6 95 only moved to defend it Knight c5
winning material of course if the brook
moves I take on b7 if I get to take on
b7 even if you take back night is coming
to d6 those Knights are just terrorists
just terrorists so he decided to do this
takes takes rook 8 7 here here check 95
the crowning point of the game and
capablanca resigned really a masterpiece
one of Lasker's best games again I know
that I did it somewhat injustice by
going over it relatively fast but time
is limited it's only a one hour lecture
but when you look at the final position
this is a position that I can look at
more than I can look at a picture in a
museum because it's just complete and
utter domination to think who the player
with the black pieces is again fantastic
two active rooks up material 96 is
coming with checkmate just a complete
route brilliancy do we have any question
about this position about this game at
all anybody okay then we'll see King
number 2 and now again it's a beautiful
example of adjusting to who you play now
he's playing against Frank J Marshall
and he is known as one of the better
American players of the era okay this is
the beginning of the 20th century we
I've mentioned in my previous class and
previous lecture I mentioned Marshall
and he was definitely a top Grandmaster
level player known as the American Foxx
because he was a very tricky tactician
this guy really knew how to play
tactical aggressive chess
watch what he does what Lasker dr.
Lasker the scientists that I should I
say the the planner look what he does to
someone who is a tactician so II 45
3 9 f 6 I know that that the patter of
Defense has a reputation for being very
quiet and draws but we know that it's
not really true in many variations blood
gets to play stuff like a 5 rue k 6 the
rooks wings over F 5 with the knight on
e4 there's some aggressive variation so
that's what that's what Marshall has in
mind so ok takes g6 Knight back Knight
takes so far very very normal and
everybody knows nowadays that b4 is one
of the main lines Knight c3 gaining
popularity but lore Alaska does
objectively it may not be the most
alarming move most venomous move but
remembering who the opponent is look
what he does Queen e2 I will bet you
anything that already in this position
Marshall lost the smile on his face he
already knows it is going into an ending
the Queen's are about to go off the
board not what he wanted but what he
need their queen e7 d3 Bishop g5 I mean
9 of 6 Bishop g5 okay
now Marshall had to make a decision a
real tough decision is he going to bite
the bullet and play Queen takes e to
right into this ending with no life a
black only white can gain anything it's
just a completely even ending or is he
gonna try to play for more but when you
play for more the risk risk exists now I
can tell you that this is move number 7
and he avoids the trades of Queens and I
can bet you that in 15 moves he curses
himself swears at himself why didn't I
trade Queens
so watch Bishop e6 okay Knight c3 97 so
far normal castles long the natural plan
h6
good move g5 9 h5 so already we have
received we are looking at the position
that is completely as symmetrical and
very very exciting of course black is
about to gain the - Bishop is gonna take
the bishop on g3 a pitcher but the
position is not without dangerous d4
Knight XG 3 okay I can tell you that
rushing to take the bishop is not
necessarily the best decision
that bishop as far as I can see wasn't
going anywhere
there are several reason not to rush
because when you take and and I take
with the H pawn the H file opens there's
a pin against this rook and the black
Queen is kind of tied down to defend
against this pawn so no immediate or not
a big mistake to take but no rush but it
took took and now he played the move g4
again very typical to style he cannot
stand this passive position there's not
much happening it's almost like a boring
game right now right you're wondering
Aviv why did you choose this game
believe me you'll be compensated shortly
the game is gonna get very exciting but
this is what he's doing he is basically
kind of reeling him into the trap into
the kind of position that only white can
benefit so here here okay and now he
makes an inaccuracy d5 I don't like this
move at all I think that if he would
have played Knight b6 then maybe I never
would have shown you this game because
that game would just somehow get lost in
the anthology of games that was played
played among between good players but he
plays d5 and now like Casper himself
says he is one move away from happiness
or actually I think I analyzed it sorry
I said that so black is one move away
from happiness if he just gets to Castle
without consequences life is gonna be
good instead Lasker starts now with a
fantastic plan and I know that Marsha
was planned for it he planned for he saw
the next move but he completely miss
evaluated the continuation that happened
in the game so let's see if anybody has
an ID if you're if you've seen the game
please don't say it because that's
unfair but if you haven't seen it let's
see if you can think what is the what is
White's plan here and those who watch
the game at home we should really pause
the video and look for yourself because
it's really it's nice I have to tell you
that when I give seminars or lectures to
masters we usually start from this
position and I'm asking them ok come up
with a plan here what would you play if
you were white and I can tell you that
some of the most common moves that I
hear are like King B one moving the King
away from that's a normal move in there
in the queenside castling but it's not
very urgent and other move that many
people say is played
queen bee - or queen III so the bishop
from f1 can get out of jail can't
disagree with that either some people
suggest the the tricky rookie one with
the intention of sometimes may be
threatened 9f5 all this is very nice but
Lasker chose a really neat plan at first
this move looks really awesome
then black has an automatic forced
response and then queen bee five very
good excellent move the queen is
attacking both the b7 pawn on d5 pawn at
first you think wait a minute with the
knight on b7 being pinned how does black
even defend this pawn this just looked
like white is just winning a pawn and
game over but instantly martial castle
and then you say to yourself wait a
minute I'm seeing a pawn on d5 and yeah
I mean I see that there are all kinds of
Forks but the knight is attacking the
Queen with a temple check and after
Knight takes d5 let's examine it okay if
I go Queen g5 check then the knight is
going to go back to e3 saving itself and
blocking the check and if you take the
Queen guess what my bishop is protecting
it so why can't Lasker just take the
pawn well let's just show how conniving
someone like marshal was in this
position he would have just taken takes
Queen g5 check winning winning a piece
because he's forking the king and queen
the Oscar would have had to take
pawn takes and oopsie the knight can't
move because rook h1 is undefended
so now we understand that that how much
marshal appreciated his danger he knew
that the pawn is not really capture ball
so he canceled what he didn't appreciate
is Lasker's continuation which was very
very strong he is not interested in that
Center poisoned pawn poison center pond
at all and he continues appreciating
that with minimal forces he is going to
conduct a tremendous attack Queen a5 all
of a sudden I'm sure that here I think
that all of a sudden
dropped all of a sudden I think that
Marshall realized that he is not going
to come out out of this problem that he
has he is a good enough attacking player
to appreciate that he is in trouble
now obviously the poem a7 is being
attacked and you think yourself wait a
minute how am I gonna defend it believe
it or not by now the computers are
giving up on the phone they just say
play something like c6 give up the poem
87 and start praying to God that maybe
you'll survive the ending good luck but
a human can't do something like that
he realized that King b8 is going to
lose precisely after night b5 with a
double attack right after King b8 night
b5 attacking pawn 87 attacking pawn c7
that's all she wrote right so he decided
to play a six and he thought okay I mean
white doesn't really have a lot of
firepower if you look at it right now
yeah the rook is back home the bishop is
home the rook is here the knight is
vacationing somewhere on the the other
hemisphere right but Lasker already
prepared for this and he doesn't need a
second invitation and he does too
Marshall what Marshall usually does to
his opponents BAM Bishop a6 ask and you
shall receive
and again the computers are saying okay
you lost the pawn go key b8 survival
mode damage control but the human again
can do it having said a he has to say B
and he took the bishop
check King ba Tommy move Knight b5 okay
so far it doesn't need special
introduction the threatening Queen a7
and Queen c7 checkmate
and he played Knight b6 now the queen is
controlling c7 for a moment you look at
the position you say well nice you
attacked very nicely you sacrifice the
piece but looks like Black has more than
plenty more than enough resources to to
hold but not true but the question is
you have to find just one little move
and he finds it rook to d3 now black is
lost there's no defense against ideas
like a four rook b3 and black is just
too tied down to defend against the c7
attack notice that every time the threat
will be check and mate and if you play
something like bishop CA then it
made so he is stuck he played Queen g5
check in the case of 94 Lasker prepared
a beautiful continuation probably not
the only one to win but one of them is
very nice rook b3 looks like a mistake
because of the what's what the analysis
a but it's winning check okay
they are Niles mentioned that even f4
opening more lines as possible I'm not
going to go too deep into this game
otherwise I'll never show you the other
one King bee one check check with the C
pawn opening the C file Bishop d6 trying
to protect the mate on c7 remember I
mentioned again every move is check and
mate now why plays check knight takes D
six and everything is losing now okay
again the analysis are very deep I can't
afford to show you everything you can
see this game again in the database here
here and takes totally winning so I'm
sure that both players saw that this is
not that hard to see actually for
someone at the level of world champions
and he decided to play Queen g5 check
King b1 Bishop d6 at once not interested
in the rook when the other one is coming
into the game so rook v3 rook e8 again
hoping to survive somehow
a4 game over no defense against a five
so he played Bishop a 597 threatening
knight c6 checkmate he defended against
it and now a far just a brilliant
attacking game by Lasker if you think in
the beginning who would have thought
that there's going to be an attack
against a councilor King just hard to
believe Queen d2 takes rook check King
a2 just ignoring everything c6 Knight b5
resigned
after this Queen lay 7 QC 8 B 7 and just
meet next move so again a brilliant game
by Alaska really really impressive how
we big that plant Queen B 5 Queen 85
okay as a last game for today I'm going
to show you a game that probably is
quite famous maybe some of you already
know it and it's Lasker against Herman
Bower very very famous game famous for
initiating what later became the the
template I should say to a very famous
double Bishop sacrifice but the game
itself are really nice I have to tell
you that here Lasker is very young when
you see if you remember the previous
games you saw 1914 or now you see a game
from 1889 and he was if my memory serves
me right he was 21 years old at the time
so a very young girl Oskar is playing
this game well before he becomes a
monster but still but still he shows
that he knows how to play chess very
inventive
first of all already the signal of a
young person f4 how many times have you
seen Lasker player four not many times D
five a good principal reply and I kind
of like this reply because the ideal
setup is what what gets in the game f4
f4 Knight f3 and b3 and I like this
setup because now although Bower didn't
do that okay III if you play for example
Knight f3
then g6 can be played before white gets
two pushes pawn to b3 and if you play b3
now then the move Bishop g4 is very
annoying aiming to take the knight
whenever it comes to f3 so just a little
point about the opening so III Knight of
6 here here I don't like this move so
much I don't see any reason why not to
play the bishop out before you bury it
why not Bishop f5 for example looks like
a very normal move but again the opening
was very strange he's 6 Bishop b2 Bishop
to e7
Bishop to d3 again a very unusual way to
to develop the pieces you don't often
see that a bishop in front of the D pawn
and the bishop and the pawn on BT but
it's understandable he didn't want to
play d4 because then Bishop b2 will just
look at the center forever
we're just looking like biting on
granite just looking at the point that's
not good
he 5 is already well supported he
doesn't need a d4 pawn to support it
further so b6 normal Knight f3 and here
we play Bishop e7 okay not a terrible
move but I think that the farm black and
I'm seeing two bishops kind of x-raying
towards my intended position for my king
then I'm playing something like Bishop a
six step one let's get rid of this
Bishop trade bishops that's going to
reduce my getting mated chances by a
large margin
so Bishop d7 but it's not a mistake
because he could still save it later
you'll see Knight c3 97 castles castles
very normal now 92 he is starting to
shift pieces towards the King side but
an intention of an attack so he plays 92
I don't really like this move I think
that this this plan could have backfired
had black played correctly so after this
he played here now what do you think
black should play here like what would
you I want to hear non grandmasters
commenting on this game and I bet that
one of you will come up probably with a
proper plan here what move do you think
black should play like when I saw the
game and I saw c5 and then the game
continued I thought of myself why didn't
black do something obvious here then you
put it in the computer the computer
almost immediately concur see just you
don't need an engine to play this
miracle
I wonder what classical would have done
and he faced it what do you guys think
95 94 is not bad either by the way to
put a knight on e4 is a very very
legitimate try because if you put the
bishop in front of the pawn and the f1
already moved then good luck getting rid
of my knight on e4
so also a good move but 95 to me Knight
c5 and just taking this bishop I don't
know what Lasker would have planned I'm
assuming that he would just try to
mobilize his center maybe but ok he just
I think it will take a very strong
person to prevent
from playing this move on the board and
take my arm away so he played c5 which
is also seen natural but not not as good
night g3 there's an amassment of pieces
towards the black King we can see that
he wants it but black is still safe
Queen c7 okay no problem with that
95 the action begins this has to be a
normal move now I didn't like blacks
decision again I think that in this
position I would have played either here
or very shortly just g6 but probably
here is the I think it's almost the last
chance I have because he took on e5 that
was not good so like right now to play a
move like g6 and I will bet you that
white is not mating black the game is
very balanced I think that black is no
worse it's at least equal I don't see
any reason for black to be in trouble
after g6 but it's a very defense it's
like almost like crying before you're
hurt right it's actually not attacking
me so while I'm not gonna play g6 I'm
gonna wait until you're greater threat
then I'll play g6 if necessary but
prophylaxis has sometimes a good weapon
inches he decided to take Bishop takes
Queen c6 okay he has ideas of playing a
move like d4 it's a moment
so I played Queen e2 a6 very very quiet
last chance for g6 last call you don't
do it you pay he plays this I'm assuming
of course the intention was to play
something like b5 threatened c4 get some
counter play on the side where he has
the advantage however now the real
action begins now it's gonna be
basically Lasker again at his best he
managed to maximize the potential of his
minor pieces everything is good and good
and ready for the attack some of the
black pieces are kind of left field left
field so what do you think he did some
of you that have seen the game again I'm
sure that you know the move but
intuitively what do you think what
should you play it what's that if he
takes the knight bishop takes and I'm
attracted threatening Brook a 1 yes
Knight h5 that's what he did but again
this is a move that you can play only if
you really understand the follow up and
it's a tricky follow up but of course
there's a very strong the only defenders
of the night are like on the king at the
knight and the bishop was supporting him
so 9 h5 is going to use the knight to
eliminate some of those defenders and
already black is in trouble after - rod
life is very very difficult after a move
like this because what can you do you
already have to resort to some groveling
here for example if I'm about to capture
here and break your pawn structure you
might have to just live with that I'm
not even sure what the best defensive
move your wad would have been the knight
can't really move because g7 is attacked
taking the knight that seems like a
defensive tribe was tried in the game
and failed and yeah maybe moving the
rook I think moving if you put this in
the computer probably he will say
something like rook e8 a rogue d8
something like that just try and forget
about the 87 point the King is just
going to run to f8 and e 7 somehow try
to survive down upon which in practical
terms of course means the loss and of
course the computer Awards it
accordingly let's take a look
98 let's think if 98 here can I go
can I go Bishop takes g7 and then Queen
g-form is there any any defense against
that let's say I take you have to take
and then I'm coming here I think it's
more than the piece you have to do this
then I will take it you go here and then
I'm going to start tickling this guy
perhaps like so I know why I rather be
in this position I have a strong
preference and I'm sure everybody does
of course so yeah very very I mean very
vulnerable position for black I'm almost
certain that you have to move the F rook
so that the King can start hiding and
just pitch the eight seven point forget
about it
in the game he tried to take and of
course I'm sure you guys are analyzing
Queen takes h5 and what will happen next
I can tell you that in the game he
played a winning move Bishop 87 had he
taken here which also seems very strong
I mean look at the two bishops
criss-crossing and the rook might be
ready to jump up and over
but after f5 the dream is over now there
is no attack too late oh I just missed
the boat completely you can play rook f3
and I can easily defend my second rank
I'm just going to push one of my pawns
I'm gonna put my rook let's say on f7 at
the right time maybe even Bishop f6
trading this monster but the worst is
over here black is is really it's not
dying in the game however you'll see
again it was an unknown it's impressive
because nowadays maybe some of you have
seen it and there are the temple games
with ample example examples - how it
happened but this is the first time
Bishop takes h7 check ok so King takes
Queen takes h5 check we have a
no-brainer only move and now comes the
second shot Bishop takes g7 again before
black gets to play f6 and defend this
position we sacrifice the bishop to
completely snip the king of its
defenders it's worth to Bishop to
completely undress the black King we
have enough firepower watch what happens
takes Queen Chuck making sure that the
King doesn't get any ideas to run the
way making sure that the king is going
to go the right way and now king 8 7
luke f3 very very difficult so in the
game he went e5 giving back the piece
well what else can you do I mean it's
really bishop h4 of just rook h3 doesn't
look very good so trouble he played here
but now white wins a ton of material
back all of his investment and then some
he plays Czech Queen to h6 what else and
takes takes at first glance you might
say wait a minute this is really nice
there's no mate and lest we forget that
you won the Queen for a rock but there
were two bishops invested first but
White has a little surprise Queen d7 a
very simple fork winning one of the
bishops and the game just a brilliant
way to attack a castle King after here
here here okay I'll show you the game
for the sake of for historical reasons
played here here just giving no chance
notice I should mention notice that he
doesn't rush to take the pawn on d5
because then maybe the rook will come
here and maybe the rook can enter by
taking why right now the rooks have no
good open files let's leave it just like
that the queen is going to be the
mischievous winner
so after here here check opening the
file for our rock here
g6 well luck is just crushed the final
combination wins the rock and the game
just a brilliant billing the attack by
Alaska let's go just back one one time
to the critical position just so we can
maybe we went too fast and I want you to
enjoy it in this position after 90 xh5
again not Queen takes because of f5 but
right now you look at the king he looks
so safe with those classical three pawn
shelter and in two more moves like if
you take again a mental print of this
position takes takes takes check and
here and the blocking from being
completely defended all of a sudden it's
all by his lonesome black must give a
ton of material back and he is lost ok
guys thank you very much for listening
to the lecture I hope you learn
something and appreciated our former
world champion see you next time